cet homme c'est jeff bezos le fondateur
d'amazon il lance aujourd'hui un fonds
pour la terre le business est fade
il va y placer 10 milliards de dollars
c'est parce que l'argent de poche pour
lui qui proviennent de sa propre fortune
personnelle estimée à 130 milliards de
dollars
alors est ce un geste vraiment sincère
coup de marketing un calcul d'un calcul
fiscal j'en parle avec peugeot talpin
fiscaliste professeur en fiscalité
l'école des sciences de la gestion de
notre du québec à montréal et fondatrice
de taxes coop et qui milite justement
contre l'évasion fiscale et pour les
changements des règles du jeu
international sur ces questions de votre
réaction qu est-ce qui va si c'est
intéressant aux phoques
c'est très intéressant fait pas
surprenant de plus en plus de
milliardaires utiliser fondation privée
de charité pour pour faire des gestes de
ce genre là donc et je pense que
monsieur bedos
il faut prendre avec un grain de sel un
peu son geste très charitable il ya des
nuances apportées évidemment on sait que
donner cet argent à une fondation privée
de charité et fondations privées de
charité aux états unis fonctionne de la
même manière que ici au québec au canada
donc il faut pas penser que demain matin
il parle des milliards qui vont être
injectés dans l'environnement
bien qu'on n'a pas tous les détails en
rapport avec cette fondation là parce
que le site internet n'est pas encore
public
on n'a pas on s'est passé quoi l'entente
exactement mais s'il fonctionne de la
même manière qu'ils fonctionnent avec
son autre fondation privée de charité ou
ses autres fondations privées de charité
ou selon les règles fiscales américaines
probablement qui va se limiter au
rendement sur capital c'est à dire
environ 500 millions $ qui va être remis
à chaque année pour l'environnement donc
ça paraît bien ça paraît grise
enfin quelq'un quelqu'un qui croit la
lutte aux changements climatiques dans
500 millions par année c'est parmi les
10 milliards lui c'est comme un conte de
sa fondation d'aidé comme un compte de
banque
sauf de l'argent parce qu'on lui
reproche déjà de ne pas payer ses impôts
payés il doit de l'argent au
gouvernement oui c'est sûr que l'exemple
de monsieur buzzer c'est tellement bel
exemple est l'exemple d'amazon
parce que comme vous dites au début on
voit vous avec cet exemple toute la
chaîne de défiscalisation on sait qu
amazon paie peu ou pas de paix pas sa
juste part d'impôts en 2018 son taux
d'imposition effectif était de 6% ça
enrichit un fondateur qui devient
milliardaire multimilliardaire l'homme
le plus riche du monde et donc et par la
suite le système des fondations privées
de charité permet à cette personne n'a
de par le biais de son don qui fait sa
propre fondation qui le contrôle
lui-même
donc ça permet cette personne n'a de
réduire ses impôts peut-être ce cas on
n'a pas d'informations sur c'est quoi le
taux d'imposition monsieur berdos
il n'a jamais dit publiquement comme
monsieur fait le bruit mais si son taux
d'imposition et autour de 50% on peut
s'imaginer que l'économie d'impôt est
substantiel au moment de la création de
la fondation donc 10 milliards qui
donnait à la fondation un économie
d'impôt de peut-être 5 milliards de
dollars tandis qu'ils par qui par delà
des poches des contribuables américains
et qui récoltent les coups droits parce
que il peut poster pour l'heure pas ce
qu'il doit à m'économiser impôts parce
que fait un don et qu'est ce que récolte
les contribuables américains
contrepartie 500 millions par année donc
c'est le régime des fondations privées
qui n'est pas un bon régime
il faut se mettre à l'évidence je sais
qu'on veut y croire mais ce n'est pas un
bon région dit souvent que les gens
s'achètent une respectabilité ou une
bonne réputation avait en créant des
fondations
bien sûr on his express il s'achète une
respectabilité on a l'impression que ce
sont des personnes généreuses elles le
sont peut-être mais leurs fondations ne
sont pas généreuse alors la suite à
suivre parce que
avec cette idée de faire payer les
impôts à tous ces grandes entreprises là
on va voir s'il ya des changements de ce
côté là on espère que au lieu de partir
de grandes fondations privées de charité
que ces personnes vont finir par payer
leur juste part d'impôts qui que nos
gouvernements auront de l'argent est
paraît-il des employés paraît-il les
employés mécontents chez amazon